two brothers have sustained horrific
injuries after israeli soldiers
apparently detonated an explosive device
at their refugee camp home
one of the men who's still in hospital
shared his story with us
the army came at around 6am while me and
my family were asleep
the soldiers placed an explosive device
at the door and blew it up
i woke up from the pain in my legs and
found out that my brother was injured as
well
that's what i remember i was injured and
then arrested while i was on the
stretcher
i was in a coma for 18 days i had
surgery nine times
they even wanted to amputate my leg a
month and a half later
my father visited me and i didn't even
recognize him at first
and then i slowly started to improve but
it's now been three months
mohammed's brother has been detained
without trial according to his family
their father described to us the shock
of seeing his injured sons and
questions why it happened
i came downstairs and found both my sons
drowning in their blood their legs
shredded with pieces of flesh on the
walls
then the soldiers swarmed in i couldn't
handle seeing my children like this
it is brutal and inhuman why did they
have to use this huge explosive device
even our neighbors from two kilometers
away heard the explosion
i was allowed to visit my sons in
hospital a week later
they were in a serious condition and
then they arrested one of them without
charge or
trial he was sent to prison when i
visited him he was walking on crotches
he had platinum in his legs replacing
the bones because his bones were
shattered
israel says it was carrying out an
anti-terror raid
seizing armed military operatives
weapons and ammunition
a statement describes the brothers as
activists adding ahmad will be held in
administrative detention until march
dr reuben birko an israel defense forces
reserve
officer says he has little sympathy for
them
i can tell you and testify from the
field
that the army do not wake up in the
morning
look for what looking for what door to
break into
they have intelligence they deliberately
went to that house precisely and you
know that the palestinians
deliberately hide beyond metal doors
or human shield like women and children
how common is it for innocent
palestinians to be injured by israel
i didn't make any research about how
common but i can tell you for sure
that it's very common to any jihad
islamic activist
to hurt deliberately innocent people in
israel
and the job of the israeli army is not
to count innocent palestinian terrorists
is only to take care of our citizens
and prevent any attempt to kill them
deliberately
to kill innocent citizens in israel this
is the mission
of our idf we are not looking to hurt
innocent people
we are not waking up in the morning and
say
oh it's a long time we haven't been in
janine
it's time to break a door in janine it's
intelligence
a precise intelligence we went there
deliberately to find this
special terrorist and we too pray to
bring him
into prison that's what we did and we'll
proceed to do so
one of the brothers says the army
acknowledged the raid was a mistake
their cousin wants answers as to why
ahmad's in jail
they treat every palestinian as a threat
so we went to court because of the way
the soldiers burst
in as for ahmed they said his case is
classified and accused him of being a
member of the islamic jihad movement
even though there was nothing against
him he got six months
in prison the israeli army told me that
i was injured by mistake
a mistake made by one of the soldiers
who thought there was someone inside the
house
so they decided to burst into the house
in a brutal way which none of us
expected
after we were injured the soldiers
started arguing with each other about
why it happened
when i reached hospital they paid for
everything
and when the lawyer arrived he also said
that the army acknowledges that it's
their fault
me and my brother were both hit because
of a mistake but he was arrested because
he'd been arrested before